(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre a possibilidade
de parcelamento dos leilões judiciais.
Então, parcelamento dos leilões judiciais, vamos começar pelo
leilão da Justiça Estadual.
A gente já falou, em momento anterior aqui
do curso, que a Justiça Estadual é disparada
a que leva o maior número de imóveis
a leilão.
Qual é a regra da possibilidade de parcelamento
desse tipo de leilão?
A possibilidade de parcelamento é até 30 vezes,
com no mínimo 25% de entrada do
valor à vista.
O que você deve saber ao escolher o
parcelamento?
O valor da comissão do leiloeiro, os 5
% ali em regra, eles não entram no
parcelamento.
Então, no mínimo, o interessado em arrematar deve
ter 25% do valor da entrada do
imóvel à vista e 5% da comissão
do leiloeiro à vista.
O valor da comissão não entra, então, no
valor do parcelamento.
E o que o interessado precisa saber para
realizar a proposta?
O interessado vai indicar o índice de correção
das prestações, o índice de correção monetária.
Via de regra, é o próprio interessado em
arrematar aquele imóvel que vai indicar esse índice
de correção monetária.
O mais comum é que o interessado indique
como correção monetária o próprio índice adotado pelos
tribunais.
Os tribunais, eles têm índices próprios de correção
monetária e são esses índices que o tribunal
adota.
Então, o Tribunal de Justiça de São Paulo
tem um índice, Tribunal de Justiça do Rio
tem outro, Ceará tem outro, e aí por
diante.
Você, como interessado, vai indicar esse índice de
correção monetária.
O normal é que você indique o do
próprio tribunal.
Alguns leiloeiros, eles nem colocam essa opção para
o interessado preencher.
Eles já colocam lá de cara que vai
ser pelo índice adotado pelo aquele tribunal especificamente
que determinou o leilão.
Mas saiba que existem outros índices de correção
monetária, como o índice atrelado à inflação, taxa
selic, IGPM, e esses que os próprios tribunais
utilizam, você pode escolher.
O normal é que você indique o que
o próprio tribunal utiliza.
A lei, ela não fala de indicação de
juros que vão ser aplicados nesse parcelamento em
leilão judicial.
Então, via de regra, você não precisa colocar,
você só coloca lá a incidência de correção
monetária mesmo.
Não há a incidência de juros.
Você pode optar lá em colocar, além da
correção monetária, algum valor de juros, se o
leiloeiro colocar lá um lugar para que você
preencha isso.
A maioria também não coloca, só deixa a
correção monetária mesmo, porque é isso que a
lei fala.
A proposta, ela deve ser apresentada por escrito.
Até a data do primeiro leilão, por valor
que não seja inferior ao valor da avaliação.
Até a data do segundo leilão, por valor
que não seja considerado preço vil.
A gente já sabe o que é preço
vil, que é o valor mínimo determinado pelo
juiz e que esse valor mínimo pode chegar
em até 50% do valor da avaliação.
Se o juiz não falar nada sobre o
valor mínimo, você pode considerar 50% do
valor da avaliação.
Se o juiz estabelecer algum outro patamar, como
20% de desconto, 30% de desconto,
você deve respeitar esse patamar na sua proposta
de pagamento parcelada.
A garantia do pagamento dessa dívida parcelada em
um leilão judicial é o próprio imóvel.
O imóvel, ele vai ficar gravado com o
que a gente chama de hipoteca judicial.
Então, vamos a um exemplo prático.
Você participou de um leilão, fez uma proposta
parcelada, a sua proposta foi aceita pelo juiz
e após o leilão, após ser aceita, vai
ser expedida a carta de arrematação.
Mais à frente aqui no curso, eu vou
explicar direitinho quando vai ser expedida essa carta
de arrematação e para que a carta serve.
Mas já vou adiantar que essa carta de
arrematação é o documento que substitui uma escritura
de compra e venda.
Em leilão judicial não existe escritura de compra
e venda.
Você vai pegar essa carta de arrematação, apresentar
no cartório de registro de imóveis competente por
aquele imóvel e esse vai ser o documento
que você vai usar para registrar a propriedade
em seu nome.
Então, quando o juiz determinar que seja expedida
a carta de arrematação, ele vai fazer a
menção expressa nessa carta que aquele imóvel deve
ficar gravado com uma hipoteca judicial e vai
colocar as condições dessa hipoteca, como o prazo
de pagamento, o valor das parcelas, e isso
tudo vai constar na matrícula do imóvel.
Assim que você acabar de pagar o parcelamento
da forma como você definiu e que o
juiz aceitou, você deve fazer uma petição ao
juiz pedindo a baixa da hipoteca judicial.
O juiz, então, vai liberar essa hipoteca judicial,
vai mandar um ofício para o cartório de
registro de imóveis onde o seu imóvel está
registrado e determinar que o cartório cancele a
hipoteca judicial.
Então, você vai ser proprietário sem qualquer dívida
daquele imóvel.
Em caso de atraso de pagamento das parcelas,
o Código de Processo Civil diz que vai
incidir uma multa de 10% na soma
da parcela em atraso com as parcelas restantes.
Então, é muito importante que antes de você
oferecer uma proposta parcelada, você realmente analise se
você vai ter como cumprir ou não aquela
proposta que você está oferecendo.
Porque caso você atrase alguma parcela, vai incidir
essa multa.
E essa multa é uma multa bem alta,
vai incidir uma multa de 10%.
Então, você vai pagar somadas parcelas que você
está devendo, mas as que ainda venceriam e
vai ser aplicada essa multa de 10%.
Então, faça essa análise criteriosa para saber se
você tem ou não como pagar o parcelamento
que você está oferecendo em um leilão judicial.
Seguindo, o INAJ Implemento autoriza o exequente a
pedir que a arrematação seja desfeita ou promover
a execução do valor devido.
Então, o que significa?
Você fez a proposta parcelada, sua proposta foi
aceita, em algum momento você não consegue pagar
a proposta que você mesmo fez.
Então, você vai ser INAJ Implente com aquela
proposta, você vai estar em atraso.
Isso dá ao exequente, exequente como a gente
já estudou, é quem está executando a dívida.
Aquele que tem direito é receber um valor.
Então, o seu atraso vai dar direito ao
exequente de chegar ao juiz e pedir que
aquela arrematação seja cancelada ou de chegar ao
juiz e pedir para executar a dívida de
você.
Então, você vai ser o novo executado daquele
processo.
A gente já viu que o executado é
quem tem o valor a pagar ao exequente.
Então, você vai ser executado porque você tem
o valor a pagar ao exequente, já que
o exequente tem que receber o valor daquela
arrematação e você não cumpriu a sua proposta
parcelada.
Então, você vai passar a ser executado naquele
processo para que você pague o que você
está devendo.
E uma vez sendo executado, vai incidir o
que a gente falou um pouco antes, a
multa de 10% sobre as parcelas em
atraso, mas o total das parcelas que ainda
não venceram, que seriam pagas.
Mas vai acontecer o chamado vencimento antecipado.
A partir do momento que você para de
dever, todas aquelas parcelas futuras serão consideradas como
vencidas e sobre todo esse total vai incidir
uma multa de 10%.
Você deve saber que a proposta de pagamento
à vista prevalece sobre a proposta de pagamento
parcelado.
Então, uma proposta de pagamento à vista sempre
tem preferência sobre o pagamento parcelado, ainda que
aquele pagamento parcelado, no final do pagamento, pudesse
ser mais vantajoso.
Então, ainda que o valor parcelado no final
tenha um valor de arrematação maior, a proposta
de pagamento à vista vai ter preferência.
Isso significa que é impossível arrematar um imóvel
em leilão judicial com pagamento parcelado?
Não, porque eu já falei várias vezes que
esse mercado de leilões de imóveis é bem
inexplorado.
Existem todos os dias vários leilões de imóveis
que acabam de forma negativa, isso é, sem
nenhum lance.
Então, se não for oferecido nenhum lance à
vista, vai levar, eventualmente, o lance parcelado que
exista sobre aquele imóvel.
O que faz com que exista, sim, bastante
chance de arrematar um imóvel em leilão judicial
de forma parcelada.
Mas, às vezes, você vai precisar de um
pouco de paciência.
Pode ser que no primeiro leilão que você
tenha interesse você faça a proposta parcelada, e
depois existe uma proposta à vista que vai
ter preferência.
Essa proposta parcelada não vai servir para nada,
nem vai ser analisada.
Até a hora que vai chegar o momento
que você vai conseguir com uma proposta parcelada
levar um imóvel.
Porque aquele imóvel ou só vai ter a
sua proposta parcelada ou vai ter alguma outra
proposta parcelada, mas a sua pode ser a
mais vantajosa.
E, se for a mais vantajosa, ela vai
ser aceita.
A apresentação da proposta parcelada, ela não suspende
o leilão.
O que significa falar que a apresentação da
proposta parcelada não suspende o leilão?
Significa falar que o interessado em fazer uma
proposta parcelada vai fazer a proposta e o
leilão vai seguir normalmente.
Por quê?
Porque se o leilão seguir normalmente e tiver
um lance à vista, não importa quantas propostas
parceladas existem para aquele imóvel.
A proposta à vista, como a gente já
falou, sempre vai ter preferência.
Então, a proposta à vista vai levar aquele
imóvel.
Por isso que a proposta parcelada não suspende
o leilão.
Para dar a oportunidade de alguém oferecer um
lance à vista para aquele imóvel.
Como você vai fazer a sua proposta parcelada?
A gente já viu aqui que a proposta
deve ser feita de forma escrita.
Você não vai apresentar a sua proposta para
o juiz.
Você vai apresentar a sua proposta para o
leiloeiro.
A maioria dos leiloeiros colocam em seu site,
no caso de um leilão judicial online, um
campo para que você possa preencher a sua
proposta parcelada para aquele imóvel.
Então, você vai abrir esse campo específico e
vai fazer a sua proposta parcelada.
Colocar o valor de entrada que você vai
pagar, quantas parcelas você vai pagar, sempre respeitando,
no mínimo, 25% de entrada e, no
máximo, 30 parcelas.
Dentro disso, você pode oferecer como você quiser.
Você vai colocar um índice de correção monetária
e a incidência ou não de juros.
O leiloeiro, então, apresenta essas propostas parceladas caso
só existam propostas parceladas naquele leilão.
A gente já viu que o lance à
vista tem preferência.
Então, se existir um lance à vista, o
leiloeiro nem leva a proposta parcelada para o
juiz.
Ele só leva a proposta parcelada se só
existir proposta parcelada, uma ou mais propostas parceladas.
E o juiz vai analisar aquela proposta parcelada
para ver se ele concorda ou não que
o pagamento seja feito daquela forma que você
dispôs que iria pagar.
Havendo mais uma proposta de pagamento parcelado, em
diferentes condições, o juiz decidirá pela mais vantajosa,
assim compreendida sempre, as de maior valor.
Em iguais condições, o juiz decidirá pela proposta
formulada em primeiro lugar.
Então, lembra aquilo que a gente falou aqui
no começo do curso?
Que é normal que as pessoas interessadas em
arrematar um imóvel, deixe para dar seus lances
nos últimos 15 minutos do leilão?
Se você quiser fazer uma proposta parcelada, não
faça isso.
Faça sua proposta com o máximo de antecedência
possível.
Por quê?
Pode ser que você faça uma proposta parcelada
e outra pessoa depois faça uma proposta parcelada
igual a que você fez.
Então, a sua, por ter sido feita anteriormente,
vai levar aquele leilão na proposta parcelada, existe
essa regra, que se duas tiverem a mesma
condição, a que foi feita em primeiro lugar,
terá preferência para levar aquele bem.
Agora, saiba que até mesmo nas propostas parceladas,
pode existir esse tipo de competição.
Você foi em primeiro lugar, fez uma proposta
parcelada, pelo preço mínimo que aquele leilão oferecia
de lance.
Depois existe uma outra proposta parcelada por um
preço maior do que o valor que você
ofereceu.
Nada impede que você faça uma nova proposta
estipulando o valor superior à proposta que cobriu
a sua.
Como é que você vai saber isso?
O site do leiloeiro vai ter um campo
em que ele vai listar as propostas.
E quando ele lista as propostas, ele vai
botar o valor de cada proposta.
Então, você pode saber se foi oferecida uma
proposta superior à sua ou não.
Agora, saiba que se forem propostas iguais, a
feita em primeiro lugar vai ganhar.
Então, não aplique aquilo que a gente falou
de deixar para fazer a sua proposta nos
últimos minutos, porque isso aí pode te prejudicar
caso existam duas propostas com o mesmo valor.
Vamos falar agora, então, do leilão da Justiça
do Trabalho.
A primeira diferenciação que a gente viu do
leilão da Justiça do Trabalho foi aquela diferenciação
sobre o preço vil, que a Justiça do
Trabalho, ela não aplica o percentual de 50
% para caracterizar o preço vil.
Então, é normal que a gente encontre em
Justiça do Trabalho, um imóvel indo a 30%,
40% do seu valor de avaliação.
Outra diferenciação quanto ao leilão realizado pela Justiça
do Trabalho, é justamente quanto ao parcelamento.
A gente falou anteriormente que a Justiça do
Trabalho, ela tem pressa para pagar o trabalhador.
Então, o parcelamento de um leilão na Justiça
do Trabalho, ele é diferente do parcelamento de
um leilão na Justiça Estadual.
Como é que vai ser o parcelamento na
Justiça do Trabalho?
Existe a possibilidade de parcelar se o lance
é atingir o valor da avaliação do imóvel.
Então, nem sempre isso aqui vai ser interessante.
A gente mostrou numa aula que a gente
falou sobre o preço vivo na Justiça do
Trabalho, um imóvel que ele foi arrematado por
40% do seu valor de avaliação.
Ele foi arrematado pelo preço mínimo.
Se vocês não lembrarem desse caso, recorre lá
à aula que vocês vão assistir novamente esse
caso.
Ele tinha um valor de avaliação de R
$ 400 e poucos mil reais e foi
avaliado por R$ 170 mil reais.
Então, nesse caso, a pessoa não poderia fazer
o uso desse parcelamento na Justiça do Trabalho.
Só seria possível parcelar esse imóvel na Justiça
do Trabalho se ele atingisse o valor da
avaliação.
Ou seja, se a pessoa arrematasse pelos R
$ 400 e poucos mil do valor da
avaliação.
Isso aí não é interessante.
Então, é interessante que você tenha o valor
em mão.
Que você não faça o uso desse parcelamento.
Porque esse parcelamento não vai ser interessante para
você já que ele tem que atingir o
valor da avaliação.
Mas, vamos lá.
Caso você queira participar de um leilão na
Justiça do Trabalho e queira fazer o parcelamento,
você vai ter que, no mínimo, ofertar o
lance do valor da avaliação daquele imóvel.
E esse pagamento vai poder ser parcelado, então.
Com 30% de entrada e com um
parcelamento que pode chegar em até 12 vezes.
Agora, da mesma forma como a gente falou
anteriormente, esse parcelamento deve ser aprovado pelo juiz.
Então, pode ser que o juiz entenda que
12 vezes naquele caso não é interessante.
E aí, ele pode recusar aquele parcelamento e
mandar que o imóvel vá a leilão novamente.
A proposta, então, ela vai ser ou não
aprovada pelo juiz.
De resto, tudo o que a gente falou
anteriormente também vale para a Justiça do Trabalho.
Você vai indicar o índice de correção monetária.
Você vai indicar se vai ter ou não
incidência de juros.
Obviamente, respeitando isso que está aqui.
30% de entrada com um parcelamento em
até 12 vezes e se o imóvel atingir
o valor da avaliação.
Vamos falar agora sobre os leilões realizados pela
União Federal para cobrança fiscal.
Uma cobrança fiscal, ela pode ser por uma
dívida tributária ou uma dívida não tributária.
Quando alguém deve algo à União, a União
vai inscrever essa pessoa no que a gente
chama de dívida ativa.
Então você, a partir do momento que você
está na dívida ativa, você está oficialmente devendo
para a União.
E a União, ela pode realizar leilão para
vender algum bem seu para que você possa
quitar o que você deve à União.
Nessa hipótese de ser um leilão realizado pela
União Federal, vai ser aplicada a regra da
portaria da Procuradoria Federal da Fazenda Nacional.
Essa portaria é a portaria 79 de 2014.
O que fala essa portaria sobre parcelamento desse
caso específico?
O parcelamento, ele vai ser por no máximo
60 prestações com parcelas mínimas de 500 reais.
E que o parcelamento, ele fica limitado ao
valor da dívida ativa que está sendo executado.
Então vamos a um exemplo prático disso.
Você deve 100 mil para a União.
Esses 100 mil reais estão cadastrados em dívida
ativa.
Você não paga a União.
A União vai fazer um leilão do seu
imóvel para que ela possa receber.
Vamos supor que você tem um apartamento e
esse apartamento ele vale 400 mil reais.
Então eu estou interessada em arrematar esse apartamento.
Caso eu queira pedir o parcelamento desse seu
imóvel que eu quero arrematar em um leilão
realizado pela União Federal, eu vou poder parcelar
o montante da sua dívida ativa.
O seu montante aqui no nosso exemplo é
de 100 mil reais.
Então eu posso parcelar esse 100 mil reais
em até 60 vezes.
A diferença eu vou ter que pagar à
vista.
Como a gente estava falando de um imóvel
de 400 mil reais, a diferença de 400
mil para 100 mil é 300 mil.
Então eu poderia parcelar 100 mil reais e
teria que pagar à vista 300 mil reais.
É isso que fala essa portaria da Procuradoria
Federal da Fazenda Nacional.
Você pode parcelar somente o valor montante da
dívida ativa.
O valor que exceder o que está inscrito
em dívida ativa, você deve pagar à vista.
Para que a União faça um leilão de
um imóvel de alguém, ela tem que recorrer
ao Poder Judiciário.
Ela não pode de forma automática leiloar um
imóvel de alguém.
Então ela vai ter que recorrer ao Poder
Judiciário e como a gente está falando da
União, esse Poder Judiciário que vai julgar essa
ação da União é o Poder Judiciário Federal.
Então saiba que esse processo da União vai
ocorrer na Justiça Federal e nesse processo da
União seria aplicado essa regra da Procuradoria da
Fazenda Nacional.
E nos outros leilões realizados pela Justiça Federal?
Porque a Justiça Federal não julga somente processos
diretamente vinculados à União Federal.
Ela julga qualquer outro processo que tenha entidades
vinculadas ao Poder Federal.
Um exemplo disso é a Caixa Econômica Federal.
A Caixa Econômica Federal é uma entidade federal
ligada ao governo federal.
Então para você processar a Caixa Econômica Federal,
você não vai na Justiça Comum, você vai
na Justiça Federal.
Então existem vários outros casos que a Justiça
Federal também julga além daqueles casos que a
gente acabou de ver, que é a própria
União levando o imóvel de alguém a leilão.
E como é que fica essa regra de
parcelamento nos outros casos da Justiça Federal?
Nos casos que não envolvam diretamente a União
em uma cobrança de uma dívida que ela
tenha.
Esses outros casos podem seguir a regra da
Procuradoria de Fazenda Nacional, ou seja, permitir o
parcelamento em até 60 vezes, ou eles podem
seguir a regra da Justiça Estadual.
Vai depender da previsão do edital do leilão.
Então o edital do leilão da Justiça Federal,
ele pode colocar a regra da Procuradoria Federal
até 60 prestações, com no mínimo R$
500,00 de parcela, ou ele pode colocar
a regra geral do Código de Presa Civil,
que é a regra que sempre se aplica
à Justiça Estadual, que é o parcelamento em
até 30 vezes, sendo no mínimo 25%
de entrada.
Você deve olhar no edital do leilão específico
para saber qual vai ser essa regra na
Justiça Federal.
E o arrematante com nome negativado?
Ele pode ou não pode participar de parcelamento
de um imóvel que está indo a leilão
judicial?
A regra é que pode.
Então, essa é uma vantagem para quem, eventualmente,
está com nome sujo, conseguir arrematar o imóvel
de forma parcelada em leilão.
No leilão extrajudicial, que é o leilão realizado
por bancos, dificilmente a pessoa que está com
nome negativado vai conseguir um parcelamento ou financiamento.
Porque o banco vai pesquisar o histórico daquela
pessoa para saber se ele empresta ou não
o dinheiro para aquela pessoa.
E os bancos, via de regra, não emprestam
dinheiro para quem está com seu nome negativado.
Já o leilão judicial, o juiz, ele não
costuma fazer essa análise se a pessoa é
uma boa pagadora ou não, se a pessoa
está com nome negativado ou não.
O juiz, ele pode pegar aquela proposta e
mesmo a proposta de uma pessoa negativada, como
a justiça não costuma fazer essa busca, ele
pode conceder o parcelamento.
Saiba que em qualquer caso de parcelamento, se
você estiver com seu nome limpo ou com
seu nome negativado, aquele imóvel que você está
arrematando, ele vai garantir o pagamento daquela dívida.
A gente já falou que o imóvel fica
com uma hipoteca judicial.
Isso vale para quem está com nome limpo
ou para quem está com nome negativado.
Agora, se existe uma possibilidade de uma pessoa
com nome negativado participar de um leilão de
forma parcelada, essa possibilidade existe somente no leilão
judicial.
No leilão mesmo para judicial, dificilmente a pessoa
vai conseguir, porque o banco faz essa análise
prévia da pessoa, que a justiça não faz,
porque a justiça tem a garantia de que
o imóvel vai ficar com a hipoteca judicial.
Então, se for o seu caso, você pode
tentar participar de um leilão judicial de forma
parcelada e não ter maior problema quanto a
isso.
O parcelamento pode ser concedido pelo juiz.
Chegamos ao fim aqui dessa aula, que a
gente falou sobre as formas de parcelamento dos
leilões judiciais.
Tem a forma que vai ser aplicada no
leilão da justiça estadual, no leilão da justiça
do trabalho, no leilão realizado especificamente pela União
Federal e nos demais leilões realizados pela Justiça
Federal, que podem ou não aplicar a regra
da justiça estadual ou a regra específica da
Procuradoria Geral da Fazenda Nacional quando o leilão
é realizado pela União.
Cabe a você verificar no edital específico daquele
leilão qual é a regra de parcelamento que
você vai poder utilizar de acordo com a
justiça que está determinando aquele leilão.